[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 78 nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv78
nous sommes le lundi 23 octobre voici
les titres le château de Versailles de
nouveau évacué hier en raison d'une
fausse alerte à la bombe c'est la 7e
fois en 8 jours que le site des Evelin
fait face à sa situation et de multiples
fermetures qui pourrai entraîner de
multiples conséquences notamment sur le
tourisme reportage en début
d'édition les premières journées
nationales de la réparation se sont
tenus pendant tout le weekend une idée
réparer plutôt que jeter quand cela est
possible et une nécessité réduire nos
déchets dans un contexte de
réchauffement climatique et dans les
evvelines plusieurs enseignes
participaient au rendez-vous comme le
réseau envie
attrape malgré le début des vacances
scolaires les footballeurs ivelinois
étaient bien sur les terrains ce weekend
et dans le championnat de D1 senior
voisin le Bretonneux et Chatou n'ont pas
réussi à se départager 11 le score final
le résumé de la rencontre à suivre et
puis l'invité du 78 en 2e partie
d'émission près de 200 marins vont
s'élancer du port du Havre direction la
Martinique la Transat JAC Vabre débute
dimanche et parmi les participants à la
course à la voie àandio il y a un
versaillais Éric Béon naviguera sur son
bateau stand as one en compagnie de
Martin LEP dans la catégorie imoka et
nous l'avons rencontré
et c'est vous Michel mid qui avveit pu
l'interviewer bonsoir exactement bonsoir
Grégor de la rédaction tv78 alors à
l'accoutumé la victoire n'est pas dans
l'objectif de d'erric Bellon est-ce que
c'est toujours le cas ou est-ce qu'au
contraire il va pour gagner cette
transat oui d'habitude c'est plus le
message qu' veut véhiculer quand il
prend part à une course transatlantique
cette fois-ci il veut terminer haut au
classement peut-être dans un top 10 moi
en tout cas je lui souhaite il a un
nouveau bateau vous l'avez dit le bateau
de de avec Jean Lecam ils ont travaé sur
ce nouveau bateau donc pourquoi pas un
top 10 on va écouter tout à l'heure ce
qu'il a nous à nous dire Éric bon il
fera face notamment à un autre yvelinois
c'est bien sûr Louis Burton qui prendra
part à la course sur bureau valet 3 en
compagnie de Davy Baudard qui est
légèrement plus expérimenté à Louis
Burton donc logiquement Louis Burton
devrait aller être devant Éric Bellon
sur cette course dans un instant avec
vous également Michel l'actualité
sportive à retenir dans les ivelines et
aussi les derniers
résultat mais d'abord bien sûr
l'actualité autour du château de
Versailles de mardi à dimanche dernier
le site des ivelines a été évacué chaque
jour pour de fausses alertes à la bombe
une situation qui a des conséquences
pour les visiteurs qui viennent du monde
entier nous sommes allés à leur
rencontre Mathilde Francou et Gabriel
Gontier mardi mercredi jeudi vendredi
samedi et dimanche en une semaine le
château de Versailles a été évacué six
fois à cause de multiples alertes à la
bombe bah on était en cours tout
simplement au château de Versailles et à
ce moment-là on a entendu une bah une
une sonnerie nous demandant de de sortir
puis le personnel est venu nous nous
indiquer la sortie et donc on a on a
suivi on a suivi le monde en fait on
avait fait même des
pronostics pour savoir si notre cours
allait justement durer toute la journée
ou si on allait être évacué avant donc
voilà des multiples alertes à la bombe
posté via le site
moncommissariat.fr face à cette
situation les touristes sont contraints
de s'adapter c'est dommage pour les gens
qui viennent de loin nous ça on est à
Paris donc voilà le policier nous a dit
que ça devrait rouvrir dans 2h de 3h
donc je pense pas qu'on va attendre mais
on va réessayer les autres jours et on
verra oui nous sommes des touristes nous
venons de croassie nous sommes là pour
quelques jours et nous attendons pour
pouvoir aller à l'intérieur du château
de
Versailles nous avions entendu les
nombreuses alertes à la bombe sur
internet le château ouvre et ferme ouvre
et ferme
mais nous allons attendre et nous serons
heureux si nous pouvons rentrer à
l'intérieur je ne vais pas pouvoir aller
au château de Versailles maintenant
parce que j'ai une réservation pour
aller visiter la tour effffel mais je
vais peut-être revenir demain des
évacuations qui ne profitent pas au
tourisme en cette fin de haute saison le
château accueille entre 10000 et 15000
visiteurs par jour les conséquences
elles arriveront si l'information est
tellement diffusée notamment à
l'étranger que certains se disent on va
annuler notre voyage ou le reporter il y
a un certain nombre de commerçants
autour du château qui nous disent que
ils regrettent parce que par exemple ils
ont perdu une clientèle habitué à faire
des visites particulières au château des
choses comme ça selon le ministre de la
Justice ces fausses alertes ont donné
lieu à l'ouverture de 22 enquêtes
judiciaires la sanction peut aller
jusqu'à 2 ans de prison et 30000 €
d'amende et pour la première fois en 8
jours pas d'évacuation du château de
versa aujourd'hui normal le site est
fermé au public comme tous les
lundis le point présent sur le reste de
l'actualité dans les
ivelines avec les suites justement
Michel des fausses alertes à la bombe au
château de versaill l'un des auteurs a
été jugé ce lundi il avait averti je
cite le trône de Louis XIV va sauter à
plus le responsable de ce canular a été
interpellé grâce à son numéro de
téléphone il a reconnu lesffits en garde
à vue l'individu de 37 ans souffre de
schizophrénie a un casier judiciaire
vierge au chômage et toujours chez ses
parents la motivation terroriste n'a pas
été retenue il comparaissé libre devant
le tribunal judiciaire de Versailles qui
a rendu son verdict une mauvaise blague
qui lui vaut 8 mois de prison avec
surcil et des dommages et intérêts non
chiffrés deux policiers de guancour ont
été placés pendant plusieurs heures en
garde à vue après l'utilisation de leur
arme à feu les faits se sont produit ce
dimanche un individu a été pris en
chasse vers 15h sur la commune de
guyancour la raison ce jeune homme de 19
ans avait dérobé un véhicule avant de de
prendre la fuite jusqu'à viler le bacle
c'est là que le forcené a tenté de
forcer un barrage de policiers les deux
fonctionnaires ont alors ouvert le feu
le blessant au thorax un temps placé en
garde à vue les deux policiers ont été
remis en liberté ce lundi matin selon le
parquet de Versailles les jours du
fugitif ne sont plus en danger c'était
ce matin le ministre délégué chargé du
numérique Jean-Noël Barot était à
Montini lebretonneux exactement grégoryi
le ministre était venu pour soutenir un
projet de formation qui vise à renforcer
l'employabilité des talents son nom la
talent Acad ÉIS son objectif susciter
des vocations notamment chez les jeunes
femmes sur les métiers scientifiques et
techniques pour se faire le programme
Saxe autour de trois thèmes éduquer
formé et recruté on écoute Sophie Duma
la directrice de la formation qui nous
en dit plus au micro de Clara de Frutos
sur le programme incubateur par exemple
nous avons aujourd'hui une communauté
avec à peu près 700 apprentis donc à qui
nous proposons des des activités
diverses par exemple des des visites de
sites des des rencontres avec des
start-ups parce que ces jeunes ils sont
friants de ce monde de des
start-ups donc c'était à l'école 2600 je
n'avais pas précis on termine avec plus
de légèreté pour pour ces actualités du
jour une idée de sortie en ces vacances
de la tous tout à fait grégoryi le 28
octobre à Versailles une Murder Pary
sera organisée pour fêter Halloween une
sorte de jeu de rôle grandeur nature
dans l'ancien domaine de Madame
ellisabeth transformer pour l'occasion
une base militaire et scientifique pour
développer des super soldats mais tout
ne va pas se passer c'est comme prévu
votre objectif est simple résoudre
l'enquête et fuir les zombies pendant 45
minutes comptez 25 € par personne et 16
ans minimum pour vivre cette expérience
merci Michel et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi près de chez vous vous êtes
témoins d'une information qui vous fait
réagir dans les ivelines n'hésitez pas à
la partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
news le weekend dernier c'était les
premières journées nationales de la
réparation le but promouvoir cette
pratique auprès des Français pour éviter
de jeter quand cela est possible tout
dans un contexte d'urgence climatique
pour réduire nos déchets et qui est donc
plus que nécessaire justement attrape
l'entreprise d'économie circulaire envie
est engagé dans ce combat le reportage
de rine
r machine à café frigo ou encore
lavelinge ce n'est peut-être pas visible
mais ces appareils ont déjà du vécu
c'est l'association envie attrape qui
leur a donné une seconde vie donc j'ai
cette machine là
qui est arrivé sous
garantie donc le problème qu'elle avait
c'est que la cuve était carrément tombée
on avait le la traverse là qui était
cassée donc je l'ai
remplacé et là je m'aperçois qu'elle
disjoncte donc c'est un problème de
résistance h garantie le coût de cette
opération s'éléverait à 150 € grâce à ce
système le client économise en ne
rachetant pas de nouvell machines le
fait de bah juste changer la essence
c'est bénéfique déjà pour la planète
puisque ça nous évite de le fer à la
poubelle et puis bah c'est réparable en
vrai tout est réparable des cas comme
celui-là envie en compte un bon nombre
installé à trappe depuis 11 ans
l'entreprise reconditionne entre 200 à
300 appareils chaque mois un phénomène
qui s'observe notamment depuis la mise
en place du bonus réparation c'est un
dispositif qui a été mis en place il y a
environ 1 an et qui
permet à propriétaire d'une machine en
panne de bénéficie d'une remise chez des
réparateurs agréés les réparateurs agré
qu' répare des bonus qui vont de de 10 à
45 € en VI compte aujourd'hui 52
établissements en France à terme elle
souhaite développer un centre de
formation dédié à ses futurs
salariés allez c'est l'heure de parler
sport dans le
[Musique]
78 c'est avec vous Michel vous êtes
toujours installé avec moi en plate all
on est très bien alors on joué ce
weekend la 4e journée du championnat de
première division de district voisin et
l'équipe 2 de Chatou se sont séparés sur
le score de un but partout ce dimanche
le résumé du match des images de Patrick
Jacques de
dixmud un match pour se rapprocher du
podium de D1 de district les Bleus de
voisins recevaient les jaunes de Chatou
pour le compte de la 4e journée en
première période les deux équipes du
milieu de classement s'observent et ce
sont finalement les C qui ouvre le score
sur ce bel
enchaînement 1 à0 malgré les tentatives
des deux côtés le score n'évoluera pas
avant la pause on a fait une bonne
première mi-temps je pense voilà on
domine on gagne 10 on un peu de mal à se
mettre en route mais onè un but assez
logiquement pr mi-temps au retour des
vestiaires voisin accélère pour revenir
dans la partie se procure plusieurs
occasions l'équipe locale est récompensé
avec ce petit bijou inscrit à la 54e
minute
voisin aurait pu l'emporter mais le
gardien de Chatou est attentif sur
chaque situation dangereuse score final
un partout les joueurs ont une très
bonne réaction sur la seconde mi-temps
et c'est logiquement qu' score on aurait
pu pousser un peu pour all chercher ce
deè but mais on s'en concent pour
aujourd'hui on fait des bons matchs nos
matchs sont cohérents mais
malheureusement on prend pas les trois
points donc on stagne un peu dans le
championnat on va essayer de d'inverser
ça dès la semaine prochaine en seconde
voilà seconde période on a du mal
rentrer dans dans notre match ensite on
prend but sur une touche sur une voilà
une mauvaise mauvaise appréciation d'où
d'où valait le ballon sur un marquage
après félicitation numéro 10 qui met un
très beau but voilà au classement les
Vinois remontent à la 5e place du
championnat les Catoviens sont quant à
eux 7e la prochaine journée est
programmée ce dimanche 29 octobre voisin
recevra l'équipe 3 du FC Manois et
Chatou accueillera moropa on remonte à
présent de quelques divisions on va
parler de la 3e division française le
championnat national le FC versaill joue
joué ce weekend à domicile contre
Marignan ginia côte bleue du côté du
stade jamboin mauvaise opération pour
les joueurs de la cité royale ils se
sont fait rattraper en fin de match
alors qu'ils avaient ouvert le score à
la 52e minute par Jordan mendz cororea
ils ont concédé l'égalisation la 87e
minute un terrible scénario qui a des
conséquences au classement le FC
bersaill est 9e avec seulement trois
victoires au compteur ils sont à 5
points du podium le rugby avec le
championnat de fédéral 2 on joué ce
weekend pour le compte de la 5e journée
du championnat deux victoires une
défaite pour nos clubs villinois plaisir
a enchaîner une nouvelle victoire contre
ami1 le score est sans appel 54 à 3 le
MLSGP s'est imposé 19 à 17 contre
plousané enfin versaill s'est incliné 27
à 19 contre orsé au classement les
Plaisirois sont premers avec 6 points
d'avance sur le second versaill est 7e
et le MLSGP est 10e sur 12 la belle
performance du weekend à mettre au
crédit de l'équipe de France de rugby
féminin et une ivelinois justement à
briller dans le 15 féminin ce samedi la
France a battu la Nouvelle-Zélande sur
ces terre sur le score de 18 à 17 elles
prennent donc le revanche équipe qui les
avait battu en demi-finale de la Coupe
du Monde 2022 une yvelinoise a brillé
pendant la partie vous la voyez sur
cette image c'est notre ivelinoise
Émilie Boulard la sportive à récupérer
un ballon sur un contre dans les 22 m
français et l'international au 23 à
sélection a placé une terrible
accélération de 80 m c'est elle qui a
permis à l'équipe de France de prendre
les devants et n'hésitez pas à Leser
voir l'essai de 80 m on peut pas vous le
montrer ici mais il est sublime bravo à
Émilie Boulard le rugby encore alors la
Nouvelle-Zélande chez les filles a perdu
mais du côté des masc on est toujours
bien sûr en lise dans cette Coupe du
monde de rugby puisqu'il y a une finale
qui va jouer contre l'Afrique du Sud et
les all black vont préparer justement ce
grand rendez-vous dans les Yvelines oui
les All Black ne vont pas changer leurs
habitudes pour cette finale on ne change
pas une recette qui fonctionne he
greégoryi ils ont préparé leur
demi-finale contre l'Argentine à Croatie
sur scène et ils vont préparer leur
finale contre l'Afrique du Sud à Croatie
sur scène ils vont s'entraîner cette
semaine sur le terrain municipal
omnisport de la ville tous les
entraînements seront logiquement à Hu
clos la rencontre contre les springbx
est programmée ce sa i 28 octobre à 21h
au Stade de France un pronostic
ouis une victoire desb je pense oua je
vois aussi on les on les donnit pas
vainqueur avant la Coupe du monde mais
je pense qu'ils vont aller loin ils sont
déjà en finale et ils vont peut-être
remporter ce Mondial atttionor on est
enregistré hein enreré moi je suis très
mauvais en pronostic il faut le rappeler
aussi un mot de handb à présent Michel
en National 3 masculine ça va très bien
pour le chaîné Eveline handb les ilinois
se sont imposés ce samedi à domicile
contre les derniers Gonfreville le score
est sans appel là aussi un 39 à 19 au
classement le chînet est toujours
premier avec 17 points engrangé en 6
matchs disputés cette saison du tir à
l'arc pour terminer une compétition de
tir à 18 m en salle était organisé ce
samedi dimanche au complexe sportif
Pierre de Coubertin à montinil au
bretonux des dizaines de concurrents
étaient présents pour ce rendez-vous il
venait principalement des ivelines
également de les sones et des hautes
scènes on écoute le président et
organisateur de la compagnie d'arc de l'
s montiny broteneux au micro de tv78
c'est une compétition donc dite
sélective pour le championnat de France
alors alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
sélectif cela veut dire que les archers
sur la saison sale qui qui démarre en
fait en octobre qui se termine vers le
donc en janvier février et bien vont
faire unensemble de compétition et les
trois meilleures compétitions seront
comptabilisées en arc classique chez les
femmes améico qui a emporté la
compétition et chez les hommes Antoine
Michon remporte ce rendez-vous au niveau
du classement équipe et l' cours termine
3è derrière ici les moulinau et Chaville
merci Michel pour ces actualités
sportives on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine al sera pas avec moi mais vous
serez bien en plateau hein Mo je serait
là normalement serit toujours là pour
nous parler de ces actualités Sportiv
avant de passer à la suite on va jeter
un coup d'œil aux prévisions météo de
demain avec des éclaircis au menu de
votre matinée yvelinois ce mardi il fera
jusqu'à 12°gr à mantelajolie 11°gr à
Oudan et Versailles 10°r à Rambouillet
l'après-midi le ciel se voilera par
endroit compté 14°gr à Rambouillet et à
Versailles il fera 15°gr dans le secteur
de Houdan et 16°gr à Mantel jolie et
demain mardi 24 octobre nous fêterons
les Florentins à tout de suite l'invité
du
[Musique]
78 la Transa JAC Vabre débute donc ce
dimanche près de 200 skippers vont
prendre le départ du port du Havre
direction fort-de-fance en Martinique
pour une course à la voile en duo parmi
eux des ivelinois on a parlé il y a de
semaines sur ce plateau de Louis Burton
mais il y aura aussi erriic bon le
versaillais naviguera sur son bateau
standas one en compagnie de Martin le
PAP dans la catégorie imoka Michel el
Mido vous l'avez rencontré on regarde
tout de suite son interview avec Patrick
Jacques de dixmud au moyen technique la
conférence de presse de la Transat
Jacques Vabre 2023 vient tout juste de
se terminé il y aura deux ivinois au
départ de cette compétition il y aura
notamment Éric Bellon le versaillis
alors Erric tu repars sur cette Transa
Java pour la deuxème fois et ouais la
première fois cétait en 2015 avec Sam
Goodchild qui aussi participe cette
année et là cette année avec Martin le
pape donc je super content et surtout là
cette année j'y vais avec un bateau que
j'ai construit que j'ai coconçu avec
Jean Le Cam et David Raison donc la
dernière fois c'était avec un bateau que
j'avais racheté un bateau d'occasion là
c'est avec vraiment mon bateau donc je
suis très très heureux d'être là quoi et
qu'est-ce que ça représente pour toi la
Transa javaban bah c'est une c'est une
transate qui est assez mythique hein
1993 la la première a tous les les
grands champions que que j'ai lu dans ma
jeunesse qui ont participé donc j'ai
l'impression de marcher sur leur trac au
niveau du parcours on part du Havre pour
arriver en Martinique quelles seront les
difficultés peut-être à à éviter pendant
la compétition ah il y en a plusieurs
déjà il y a le départ qui est toujours
un moment sensible on a déjà parlé
ensemble et il y aura beaucoup de bateau
hein cette année voilà on est on est
quasiment sans bateau même s'il y a des
départs séparés donc ça c'est une très
bonne nouvelle donc les imoka on est
déjà enfin on va être 40 donc déjà c'est
pas mal donc déjà voilà échapper au
départ pas taper d'utre bateau ensuite
sortir de la Manche la manche c'est
quand même un c'est un gros dossier
parce qu'il y a des courants très très
forts et puis ensuite prendre les
alisées passer l'équateur une fois et
notamment la
zone de convergence intertropiticale
donc c'est l'endroit où le vent ne
souffle plus horizontalement mais
verticalement il faudra pas le passer
une fois mais deux fois et puis après
aller vers les les Antilles donc ouais
c'est semé d'embû tu vises quoi sur
cette compétition tu vises une place
dans le top 10 dans le top 15 qu'est-ce
que tu vises
je raisonne jamais comme ça
euh on a un bateau neuf avec Martin on
commence à bien se connaître euh moi ce
que je veux c'est qu'à la fin on soit
très fier de nous alors c'est pas un
résultat qui va nous rendre fier si ça
se trouve on va avoir des des tas de
problèmes et on va arriver dans les
derniers mais peut-être qu'on on sera
très fier de ça ou alors on aura pas de
problème le bateau va s'exprimer à son
gros potentiel et on va être peut-être
on va peut-être gagner on va peut-être
être devant je sais pas et moi ce que je
veux c'est être fier à la fin c'est
voilà je veux donner mon maximum sur
certaines compétitions tu as prené la
lenteur si si je peux dire au niveau de
la navigation cette fois-ci tu gommes
tout et tu vises la vitesse euh sur la
Goette oui j'ai j'ai participé à la
route du Rome en 2018 sur une goelette
classique et c'était pour voir si je
pouvais atteindre
justement la cette satisfaction sans la
la vitesse et l'adrénaline et c'était
une grande découverte et j'ai découvert
qu'en fait dans la vie il faut savoir
accélérer et freiner et souvent on fait
que accélérer et j'étais très content de
freiner mais là c'est sûr que j'y vais
pour accélérer je freinerai plus tard on
va parler de stand as one parle-nous du
projet un stand as one c'est la
continuité de comme un seul homme qui
s'est anglicisé donc c'est une une
action pour promouvoir l'aventure
collective donc on est associé à une une
goélette la fameuse goélette avec
laquelle j'ai traversé en 2018 on
embarque des jeunes de la ruralité ou
des quartiers défavorisés pour leur
apprendre justement le à aller vers
l'aventure collective pas dans le
recement sur soi et puis au niveau
sportif c'est aussi un un projet qu'on a
mené avec Jean Lecam pour faire des
bateaux révolutionnairement sobres et
tout un
développement mutualisé donc c'est à la
fois de l'aspect sociétal et l'aspect
environnemental et moi j'aime bien à
penser qu'on peut avoir une performance
respectueuse de la nature et de l'homme
c'est c'est ça Stan parleous de ton
bateau je crois qu'il est nouveau si je
me trompe pas ouais on l'a mis à l'eau
au mois de juin c'est un bateau donc que
j'ai coconçu avec Jean Lecam et David
Raison qui est l'architecte donc c'est
un bateau qui est un bateau à dérive
droite c'est le seul bateau neuf à
dérive droite de toute la toute la
classe c'est un bateau qu'on a voulu
moins cher moins poant moins émetteur de
déchets aussi donc c'est un bateau qui
pour nous est l'avenir puis que je
trouve que pour ma part l'avenir est à
la sobriété à la simplicité et pas à la
complexité donc voilà c'est une
proposition qu'on fait avec Jean Lecam
et et on pense que ce bateau peut être
aussi performant ou peut-être mieux plus
plus performant que certains bateaux
particulièrement sur le vent des globes
qui est notre notre objectif avec ce
bateau oui justement j'allais parler du
vent desgobes tu vas partir avec ce
bateau sur le vent des globes c'est
l'objectif on a dessiné ce bateaul avec
gens pour le le vent des globes et donc
notre l'idée c'est d'aller faire une
performance sur le vent desgobes ça sera
ton deuxème vend des globes qu'est-ce
que tu vises pareil sur cette
compétition
moi c'est de me battre avec les
meilleurs et donc tous ceux qui ont des
bateaux neufs à foil c'est les bateaux
qui volent nous je veux démontrer avec
Jean Lecam queon peut avoir on peut
faire la même performance ou être encore
meilleur en pensant complètement
différent et en étant plus sobre plus
simple moins cher plus accessible
dernière question qu'est-ce qu'on peut
te souhaiter pour cette Transat Jacques
Vabre 2023 Eric
ben amener stazwan le plus haut possible
et puis être heureux voilà et faire
faire vivre cette course du mieux
possible à nos partenaires qui nous
suivent qu'on cette hardiesse de suivre
un projet qui est radicalement différent
des autres voilà et qu'on qu'on soit
heureux tout à la fin de de la belle
performance quelle qu'elle soit en fait
un petit mot pour les Versaillais qui
vont te suivre sur la compétition allez
vive versaill c'est la plus belle ville
du monde merci à Éric Bellon la trans ja
Vabre 2023 partira le 29 octobre depuis
Le Havre pour rejoindre la
Martinique voilà c'est la fin du 78
merci pour votre fidélité dans un
instant une journée avec et moi je vous
retrouve demain pour une nouvelle
édition très belle soirée sur
[Musique]
tv78